Das am weitesten entfernte Objekt, das Menschen
je untersucht haben, ist noch ungewöhnlicher,
als wir berichtet haben.
Erste Bilder sprachen ja für ein Schneemann-ähnliches
Objekt aus zwei verschieden großen Teilen.
Doch es ist ganz anders und gibt der Wissenschaft
jetzt Rätsel auf.
Clixoom Scinece & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willlkommen.
Wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Der Asteroid Ultima Thule ist 6,4 Milliarden
Kilometer entfernt und zieht im Kuipergürtel,
dem Asteroidengürtel rund um unser Sonnensystem
seine Bahn.
Noch nie wurde ein Objekt von einer Sonde
untersucht, das so weit entfernt ist.
Das alleine ist schon der Wahnsinn.
Zur Erinnerung: Beim Vorziehen an Sternen
machte das Objekt etwas sehr seltsames.
Es ist rund 30 Kilometer lang und hat eine
sehr seltsame Form.
Das wurde 2017 und 2018 festgestellt.
Mit zahlreichen Teleskopen wurde dabei die
Flugbahn von Ultima Thule beobachtet oder
wie die korrekte Bezeichnung ist 2014MU69.
Der Asteroid ist allerdings soweit von der
Sonne entfernt, dass er kein Licht reflektiert
oder nur ganz ganz wenig.
Allerdings verdeckt er immer wieder Sterne
und dabei wurde festgestellt, dass sie nicht
einfach hell und wieder dunkel werden, sonder
abgedunkelt werden, dann wieder etwas heller
werden, dann wieder etwas dunkler und dann
erst wieder endgültig hell.
Ultima Thule muss also eine sehr seltsame
haben.
Und die damals vermutete Form ist noch seltsamer,
wie jetzt bestätigt wurde.
Es besteht nicht aus zwei exakten Kugeln,
wie zunächst vermtet wurde, sondern es ist
noch verrückter.
Das war schwierig festzustellen, denn Ultima
Thule dreht sich sehr speziell und rotiert
wie ein Propeller, zeigt uns also immer dieselbe
Seite.
Und so ist die Reflektion immer gleich.
Jetzt hat die Nasa aber beim Vorbeiflug einen
Blick von hinten gegen das Sonnenlicht erhascht
und der zeigt ein noch seltsameres Objekt.
Ultima Thule besteht nämlich nicht aus zwei
Kugeln, sondern aus einer zerbeulten Nuss.
So sieht jedenfalls der kleinere Teil aus
und aus einem Pfannkuchen.
Das größere Objekt ist nämlich ziemlich
flach.
Zwar ist in dem kurzen Nasavideo nur die eine
Seite beleuchtet, aber durch die Abdeckung
von Sternen konnte das Forschungsteam ermitteln,
dass der große Teil von Ultima Thule extrem
flach ist.
Jetzt hat die NASA also die neu ermittelte
Form veröffentlicht.
Jetzt gibt es mehr Fragen als Antworten: Die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler können
sich nicht erklären, wie ein solches Objekt
entstehen konnte.
Eigentlich müsste es viel runder sein.
“Wir haben noch nichts Vergleichbares gesehen,
das die Sonne umkreist.“ sagt Alan Stern,
Chefwissenschaftler des Teams der New Horizons
Sonde.
Jetzt wird also erstmal überlegt, was das
Objekt so geformt haben könnte.
Wenn es neue Erkenntnisse dazu gibt, erfahrt
ihr es natürlich hier.
Also abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Hier geht es weiter mit Unsichtbar durch Zeitlöcher.
Geht das?
bei Neugierzone.
Richtig cooles Video.
Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!